[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[ALARM BEEPING]
[LOUD RUMBLE]
- Huh?
[ROARING]
[PEOPLE SCREAMING]
[ROAR]
- Uh-oh.
[BLIP]
[ALIEN WARBLING]
- [GRUNTING]
[CHIME]
[CLAP]
- Woo-hoo!
[STOMP]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Good morning.
Ah, that's good.
Since 2011, the first day of
GDC has been Google Developer
Conference.
Can I see a show of hands
who's here for the first time?
Wow.
Welcome.
And for all the rest of you,
thank you for coming back.
It's been a tradition
that we truly enjoy.
Fun fact-- Play is only
six years old this month.
All right.
So what's exciting is
that the market for gaming
is showing tremendous momentum.
In the last year, the
number of Android users
who have downloaded a
game doubled compared
to the previous 12 months.
And 40% of these
installs are coming
from emerging markets like
Brazil, India, Indonesia,
Mexico.
At Google, we're taking
this very seriously
and working on a ton
of different things
to help you reach
a global audience.
Today, we will talk about
a few of those things.
At Play, we are
singularly focused
on becoming the
premier destination
for discovery and distribution
of your apps and games.
Last week, we
announced a Maps API
that allows you to bring your
game into the real world.
Super exciting, isn't it?
I can see nods.
That's good.
Today, we'll also announce
that our Google Cloud Platform
can work across all platforms--
PC, console, and mobile.
We'll also have sessions
on sharing with you
the early momentum you're
seeing in ARCore as well as tips
to get you started.
Additionally, I want
to share an initiative
we kicked off last fall that is
personally of interest to me.
This is about women in gaming.
After hundreds of millions of
people who play mobile games,
49% are women.
But our research
showed that women
are less likely to identify
themselves as gamers,
less likely to engage
in gaming communities,
and less likely
to work in gaming.
Look around.
So we kicked off an initiative
called Change the Game,
where we want to empower and
celebrate women both as players
as well as creators.
In one of the
sessions today, we'll
share insights we found
from our research.
So please take time to attend.
Now, before I hand off
to the other speakers,
a few things about today.
Today's about you.
We have a whole lot
of sessions, which
is focused on sharing all
the new tools and techniques
that we have been working on.
I want to highlight
three main ones.
Immediately after
the keynote, we
will have a session on the
new platforms and innovations.
After lunch, we
have two sessions.
One which is focused on really
thinking about how you can make
your launch successful
and the strategies
that we can share with you,
and then followed by a session
on how to think about
post-launch growth
for your games.
So I hope you'll stick around.
You know, this day is about you.
If you have questions beyond
today please come to our booth
Wednesday to Friday, where
we'll have more sessions
and we'll have people who
will be there to answer
any questions you might have.
With that, I hand
you over to Mark Vela
to talk about game discovery
on the Google Play Store.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK VELA: Thank you.
Thanks so much, Purnima.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Mark Vela.
I'm the head of games
merchandising for the Americas
on Google Play.
And today, I'm
thrilled to walk you
through some of the
improvements we're
making to drive games
discovery on Google Play
as well as the Play Games app.
Play serves as a discovery
engine for over 2
billion Android devices.
And that spans across
smartphones, tablets,
or even your watch, TV, or car.
And Play is also
expanding beyond Android.
The catalog is now being
delivered to laptops
powered by Chrome OS.
And across all
these form factors,
Play's mission is to
bring devices to life.
And I firmly believe it's the
incredible catalog of games
that you all bring to the
platform that delivers
the most magical experiences.
I'm going to touch on
some key areas we're
focusing our efforts
to enhance discovery.
Personalization is really the
fundamental building block
that's made even more
powerful by having
great content to recommend
and more surfaces to show
those recommendations.
On top of that,
we're also seeking
to create new experiences via
deeper curation, new sections,
and new content types.
Now, a lot of the magic
of Play's recommendations
happen behind the scenes.
So I want to pull
back the curtain
and tell you all some
of the changes we've
made to match the right
content to the right user.
Late last year, we expanded
our content taxonomy
to classify games into
thousands of different topics.
And that feeds our
personalization
in a couple of ways.
First, that taxonomy is used
for our recently launched search
refinements.
You see this
illustrated on the left.
Users can now refine
and filter search terms
to distill down to more
specific content types.
So in this example,
the user initially
came in searching
for racing games.
They were presented with a
number of different filters
underneath racing games to
distill it down more to match
what they were looking for.
They chose motorcycle,
and you can
see how the content
adjusted to meet that need.
Second, this expanded
content taxonomy
also powers the recommendations
on our homepages.
So we've transitioned
our Recommended
For You collections.
They were previously based
on the 17 games categories
on the store.
We now can serve over
200 different genre
and subgenre-based
collections to our users.
So the example that
you see on the right--
rather than having a broad
collection of sports games,
we can now dynamically
maintain dozens
of different, more
specific sports collections
to meet the users' needs.
What does this mean
for all of you?
Ultimately, these
personalized improvements
give your games
more opportunities
to surface in more tailored,
relevant collections.
Now we know how important
games are to our users,
and I want to share
several changes we've
made to provide a more engaging
browse experience that's
specifically tailored to gamers.
We'll start with navigation.
As we all know, games are
very different from apps.
And we've now elevated
games to its own destination
to reflect this.
This becomes a foundation for
creating more experiences that
are unique to games,
such as more immersive
or recommendations
with video trailers
and actual screen
shots of gameplay.
We also want to give
users more control of how
they explore the catalog.
One example is a
separate premium section
that we recently launched
a few months ago.
This highlights really
the best paid games
that we have on Play.
Another great feature that we're
showing on the premium page--
hopefully most of you have seen
our games on sale collection.
This features a new
capability we have
with strikethrough pricing.
So really conveys
the great value
that users are getting
with the regular price,
slash through it, and
then the sale price.
We've really seen
awesome conversion uplift
with this new feature.
Now, within our
recommendations, we also
want to help users
decide what to install
by more clearly highlighting
the best of the catalog.
We've always had editorial
curation at Play,
but it's sometimes a
little hard for a user
to differentiate the
personalized recommendations
from the editorial
curated selections
and understand why
they should care
about this game, what really
makes these games unique.
So one of the major
focuses for this year
is creating these new
editorial experiences.
Hopefully many of you
have seen these richer,
kind of long-form
content articles
that explain to users what
we love about the games.
These editor's choice articles
are now live in 17 countries.
And in addition to a dedicated
section, the editor's choice
section you can access
from the home page.
We've also created an
evergreen placement
on both the home page
and the game's home.
We continue to add new
articles as we publish them.
We really strive to celebrate
diverse games on Google Play,
and we really think a lot
of the game play innovation
that comes with the platform
comes from our indies.
So we've put a ton of effort
into amping up our indie games
featuring via two key areas.
First, our Indie
Corner destination
continues to be improved with
more visually exciting ways
to browse the catalog
and help users discover
their favorite new indie game.
And second, we've expanded
our indie games festival
from its initial roots in San
Francisco a few years ago.
We're now running contests in
London, South Korea, Japan.
And most recently, we had our
first ever Latin American Indie
Games Festival in Sao
Paulo, Brazil, last month.
We had over 200 nominations
from developers in 17 countries
and just had
incredible engagements.
So lots of momentum
behind our indie games
program, and we're
looking to do more here.
Discovering new
games is particularly
important to gamers, and
we're approaching this need
in a couple of different ways.
Similar to the premium
page I just showed,
we've also recently rolled out a
section dedicated to new games.
Here we seek to really
showcase the latest
high-quality releases on Play.
I also want to talk about our
pre-registration program, which
continues to just drive
incredible results.
We started our
pre-registration program
about 2 and 1/2 years ago.
And during that
time, we've driven
nearly 200 million registrations
for over 300 participating
games.
We're working hard to expose
registration in multiple places
to build on that momentum
and drive even more results.
So another thing I
want to highlight
is a new feature we're testing
out right now with "Westworld"
called milestone rewards.
This just kicked off last week
after we worked with a partner
to announce this,
and what you see
here is a tiered set
of rewards that users
can earn as the
community reaches
these different
registration thresholds.
So we've already hit the 250,000
pre-registration threshold.
That unlocks this character
Lawrence for everyone
who's pre-registered, and
there are three more tiers
that users can hit as we get to
500,000, 750,000 and a million.
So really excited
about this feature.
We think it's just going
to drive a lot of momentum
to get an entire
community to drive
towards getting these rewards.
Now, the store can also do
more than just help users
find new games to install.
Should also be a
destination where
users can find out what's
happening in the games
they already have.
We know how it's hard
to sustain engagement.
We want to help out here.
So we've started highlighting
major in-game events
and LiveOps through
store featuring.
You can see an example
of the FIFA banner
we did for a squad
building challenge.
And we've also rolled
out what we're calling
LiveOps cards on Games home.
Hopefully many of you
have experienced this.
These LiveOps cards
highlight exciting events
happening right now
in those titles,
whether it's a limited-time
event, discounts, some form
of new content, a number
of different things
that we hope will compel users
to come back into the games.
Lots of exciting
improvements here,
and I can't wait to
expand this even further.
Because we're
Google, we continue
to experiment with
innovative ways
to drive more exciting
engagement with users.
So I want to actually share with
you a pilot we just kicked off.
Vast majority of
you are probably
not seeing this because it's
a very small experiment.
But we are beginning
to run experiments
that present a different
set of information,
depending on a user's
state within the game.
So on the left, you see
what a user who has not yet
installed the game may see--
ratings, number of
downloads, some screenshots,
description of the
game, things that
will hopefully get them to
try it out for the first time.
On the other hand, if a
user already has the game,
we should show them
different information.
And that's what you
see here on the right.
Some of the LiveOps
cards information I
just showed you, in-game events
that are happening right now,
new content, and
also if there has
been an APK update, some new
features, new modes, et cetera.
So we're excited about this.
We hope to see some
positive results
so that we could roll it out.
I also want to highlight some
of the amazing improvements that
have been made to
the Play Games app.
This past November,
we fully redesigned
the app to let users
easily launch the games
they have installed.
And just this past
month, we added a number
of game reengagement features.
So in addition to tracking their
achievements and leaderboards,
users can now see
LiveOps-related news
and YouTube videos.
Also, the new arcade prominently
features an innovative new tag
browsing experience
to help users
find their next favorite game.
These updates have driven
significant increases
in engagement.
We're excited to bring even more
to the Play Games app in 2018.
So that wraps up our overview
of the key improvements
we're making on the
Google Play Store
to drive games discovery as
well as the Play Games app.
Thanks so much for your time.
And now I'll hand
it off to Jonathan,
who's going to tell you about
a really exciting feature that
goes one step beyond discovery.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN KARMEL: Hey, everyone.
Sorry about that.
[LAUGHTER]
So Mark talked
about how we as Play
try to get the right
user to the right game.
And we do that through
personalization,
editorial content, and
a new games destination.
So if we've done
our job right, you
land on a store
listing page like this.
And you have one last step.
You have to click Install.
And then you have to wait.
And as APK size gets larger,
you have to wait longer.
And then if you haven't done
something else at this point
and gone out and
done something else,
you have to come
back and hit Open.
At I/O last year, we
talked about instant apps--
bringing instant to all apps.
And we now are bringing the
same technology to Games.
We call it Google Play Instant.
Roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Ha-ha!
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN KARMEL: So welcome to
Google Play Instant, where apps
and now games can
be played instantly.
And when you see that
brand, Google Play Instant,
you know exactly what
type of experience
you're about to jump into.
And on the Play Store, it
looks like a Try Now button.
And you see it here on the left.
And when you click it, you
jump in a native experience.
This is the same code as you
have in your installed game.
And the user has an option
to install while they're
in that instant experience.
And developers have been
trying a few different things.
Some do a whole level--
first level of their game.
Some do the training
level and due two battles
like "Clash Royale" does.
And some do just
smaller experiences.
The choice is up to
you as a developer.
Now, we've been running
live experiments
since December with "Clash"
and for a few other partners.
Some have launched
this morning, and some
have launched a few weeks ago.
So this live testing,
we have some early data
that we wanted to
share with you.
And so what we're seeing
from the Play Store
is 4% to 19% increase
in new players.
Those are new installations
that are incremental to what
was happening previously.
So let me try to walk you
through how that's actually
happening.
So let's go to the old
world, where you just
have an Install button.
What happens?
Let's say this whole audience
goes to the store listing page.
Now, let's say this
part of the audience,
you all are going
to hit Install.
Now, this part of the
audience, you guys
have a fear of commitment.
You're not ready to put
that 98 megs on your phone,
or maybe you just
don't understand
what it is because
it's an app icon
or the video didn't explain
exactly what the experience is.
So this part of the room,
you are going to abandon.
Now we have a new option.
And what do we see?
This part of the room, if you
were going to install before,
you're continuing to install.
There is a big bold
install button,
and that's what you came to do.
And you're going to
continue to do that.
We haven't seen even a
change in click-through rate
for install buttons.
This side of the room,
the fear of commitment.
You guys have a new option.
You have a dating option,
a first date button.
And that allows you
to try out the game
and then see if
you want to commit.
So what we're seeing
is a 25% increase
in clicks on this page.
Again, all of you are
continuing to install.
And now we're
getting an increase
in clicks on the page because
of our fear of commitment
group over here.
And have we changed
your commitment fears?
Absolutely.
30% of you that land in
the Instant experience
are now installing,
which is awesome.
We were really happy
with these results.
But at I/O last year, you never
heard me talk about Play Store.
We actually didn't even have
a Try Now button for apps
until October.
The real opportunity has always
been outside the Play Store.
So we're really excited about
the 4% to 19% early data.
But the real
opportunity we believe
is outside the Play Store, so
let's walk you through that.
First is ads.
The old world--
you click on an ad.
You land in a Play Store listing
page with an option to install.
The new world--
you click on an ad.
You land in an instant
experience with an option
to install.
In both experiences, you
have an option to install,
you're just now getting
to play and evaluate
the game as you determine
if you want to install.
Mark talked about the update
to the Play Games app.
So you have this
great pre-roll video.
And it's like a really
immersive experience.
Guess what.
You scroll up, and you see an
Instant game play collection
that you get to launch instant
experiences right from the Play
Games app.
So it's a great
discovery engine.
The third one I'm most excited
about, which is social invite.
So Ben Frenkel is
about to come up here.
He's going to do a deep dive
into Google Play Instant.
But he loves games.
He loves playing "Clash Royale."
And before I played, he would
email me and text me constantly
to join his clan.
I had no idea what this meant.
It was quite annoying.
And so I would
sometimes click the URL.
I would go to the
website for Supercell,
which would tell me to go to
the Play store, which would then
tell me to install.
And by the time I got
there, I forgot why I'd even
clicked here originally.
I lost context.
But now I click
that URL, and I'm
playing the Instant experience.
And I'm like, oh, that's
what it means to join a clan.
I get it.
I install, and I
immediately join the clan
because the context continues
with that experience.
And Supercell is actually seeing
a shift in their installs,
more coming from social
invite, because the value
proposition of the user
is that much higher.
And finally, the Play Store,
which I've already touched on.
But I just wanted to
highlight this again,
because now if you go to the
Home tab of the Play Store,
you will see the Instant
game play collection.
You can actually play all
our instant apps today.
So you should go out and
try it in your break, when
you actually have Wi-Fi.
And you can see all the live
partners that we have today.
So shifting to the
developer side,
I just want to talk a
little bit about what
we've been up to since
I/O. The first thing
is we made sure we were
backward compatible to Android
L on a billion devices.
At I/O, we were about 150
million devices or so.
So that's been a
big effort to make
sure you can reach all
your users on Instant.
The second thing was
full native support
to make sure that
Instant experience is
identical to the installed game.
Now, our effort today is
to try to get instant apps
into every developer's
hands, make sure
that anyone can
develop an instant app.
So that's kind of
been an early program
that we kicked off
end of last year.
Step one was to make sure
this is technically viable.
We weren't even sure
if it was possible.
So we had a closed beta.
We brought in game developers.
And it's very much possible.
They proved it to us, and we
were really surprised how many
developers were able to develop
an instant app in a relatively
short period of time.
So check, it's
technically feasible.
You can go from your 100-meg
app to 4 megs or 8 megs.
Second, does this actually
cause business uplift
for our developers?
And the early data
is a strong check.
We see it in the
Play Store, and we
think the opportunity's
outside the Play Store.
So that's why we're announcing
today, because we really
think that this is a huge
opportunity for our game
developers.
The next step is to make sure
that any developer can develop
an instant app, and that's
going to take a little more work
from us.
And also, we're going to
talk about partnerships
we have with Unity and IDE
support in our next talk
with Ben.
And he'll dive
into what it takes
for us to get to
general availability
in the next few months.
With that, I want to
thank all our partners.
Please give them
around of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
We really couldn't be here
talking about Google Play
Instant today without them.
They've been a huge help
in getting the technology
to where it is today.
And with that, we're going to
shift to the agenda of the day.
Back to the agenda.
Don't worry, we're coming
back to Google Play
Instant in a second.
So we're going to kick
off the Innovation
in New Platforms and the
sessions for that theme
right now.
With that, I'm going to
invite Ben Frenkel, who's
leading the game effort
for Google Play Instant.
And he's going to do a deep
dive into Google Play Instant.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN FRENKEL: Thanks, Jon,
for inviting me up here.
I'm excited.
But you know what?
I wonder if we could
look at that slide
again with all the
partners for a second?
JONATHAN KARMEL: Sure.
BEN FRENKEL: I think
there's a name missing here.
JONATHAN KARMEL:
Who would that be?
BEN FRENKEL: Limbic
is not on here.
JONATHAN KARMEL: Oh.
Well, this is our partners
that have launched.
Limbic, I believe, started
developing a week ago.
And they're trying to
do an AR game, which
I don't think is going to be
possible for instant apps.
It just can't get to that size.
So thank you, Limbic,
for all your effort.
But we're not ready to
put them on the side.
BEN FRENKEL: Well, it's actually
up on the store already.
So--
JONATHAN KARMEL: Well,
then prove that it works.
BEN FRENKEL: I will do that.
All right.
[LAUGHTER]
Now all the pressure's on me.
So can we switch to la demo?
Demo, go.
All right.
Can you see this?
All right, good.
Phew.
Demos are always stressful.
OK.
So this is "Zombie
Gunship Revenant"
from game developer Limbic.
And it's an AR game.
So the first step
here is I'm going
to open up this infrared camera
and take a look at the audience
here.
I'm not seeing a
lot of faces, but it
does make it look
like I'm already
surrounded by zombies a bit.
So I've dropped
my base down here.
Imagine I just got
here in the morning.
I'm manning my
gunship helicopter.
And of course, when
my shift starts,
large numbers of
zombies start attacking.
And thankfully, though, I
can control my helicopter
through movement in
augmented reality.
So I can zoom in to get
up close and personal
with these zombies.
And I have a bunch of
awesome weapons, too.
So I've got this sniper
rifle, which allows me
to pick them off one at a time.
And I've got these
two Gatling guns,
which allows me to mow
down large groups at once.
But my favorite by far
is the Hellfire missile.
This thing blows stuff up.
And let me find a large group
of angry, brain-eating zombies
here to demonstrate.
Oh.
That's super gratifying.
And also, by the way, a
great way to de-stress
after a hard day at the office.
And so I'm doing a terrible job
defending this case, I admit.
I'm not very good at this.
I aspire to be better.
It's not there yet.
But there's a lot going on here.
There's a lot going on here.
This game was built
entirely in native code.
It's built on ARCore, which
you'll be hearing about a lot
today.
And it loads up instantly.
And yep, I've just lost my base.
Typical.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
And what was
particularly impressive
for me at least was that Limbic
built their Google Play Instant
version of "Zombie
Gunship" in just one week.
At least, I was impressed.
And hopefully that's
given you a taste,
a taste of what's possible
with Google Play Instant.
So Jon gave you a great
overview of Google Play Instant.
And what I want to do now is
first take a step back and give
you a sense of our overall
vision for Google Play Instant
and then dive a little deeper
into what our early access
partners are doing and how
they're succeeding and building
instant apps.
And there are three
things I really
want you to take away
from my talk today.
So the first is
Google Play Instant
will transform game discovery.
Two, that top developers
are already on board
and succeeding.
And three, game devs large and
small can build instant apps.
And it wasn't that long
ago that I was talking to--
actually, I forgot the
most important part,
an audience participation
moment that I had planned.
And let me just give
you some context here.
So year after year,
we hear that discovery
persists as one of the biggest
challenges for game developers.
And so I want to
see a show of hands.
How many of you in
the audience feel
that discovery is still one
of your biggest problems
as the game developer?
OK, that's most of you.
And this is a really
meaty problem to solve.
And so it was one of the
reasons the opportunity to have
a big impact on this area
that inspired me to join
this team in the first place.
And it wasn't that
long ago that I
was talking to Jon, who I'd
been bothering with "Clash
Royale" invites for months.
And he started to
lay out the story
for bringing Instant
Apps to Games.
And as he was doing
that, it really
clicked for me, that by
bringing instant apps to games,
we have the opportunity to
transform game discovery.
And we know that
this is possible
because, in fact, we've
seen this movie before.
Whenever media becomes
instant, consumption goes up.
Speed is a huge
competitive advantage.
We've seen this with music
streaming and movies.
And before that, Google proved
the transformative impact
of speed with instant search.
Music is a particularly
good case study
on the transformative
power of instant.
There's a bunch of
studies on the subject,
and they all pretty
much say the same thing.
When music became instant,
users played more songs,
users heard more
unique genres, they
listened to more unique
artists, and ultimately they
found better matches
for their unique tastes.
It transformed how
people discovered music.
And we believe that instant
can do the same thing for you
all of you in the audience,
the game developer.
Imagine users trying more
games, exploring more genres,
and ultimately finding more
games they love to play.
That could have a transformative
impact on your business.
And that promise,
that promise is
why we want to do the
same thing for Games.
We want to turn playing into
the primary way people discover
and evaluate games.
No longer will users solely
learn and evaluate games
on the basis of icons or
text or even screenshots.
When games are instant, it'll
just be easier to play them.
And now I'd like to
show you a glimpse
at the future of game discovery
through the Play Games app.
All right.
So imagine that I
have about 10 minutes
to spend right now,
which I do not.
But imagine for a second.
If I had 10 minutes to spend and
I wanted to play a puzzle game
and my goal is to
head to the store--
or in this case, the Play Games
app-- and find a cool puzzle
game, play it, and enjoy it.
That's the goal.
The goal is to play the game.
So we kind of know how
this would go today.
So you go to a store.
You would go to the home page.
You would compare
icons and titles.
And maybe you'd go
through to the store
listings of a few of them.
And at the end of that, you
might install one or two games.
But instead, now we
fast-forward to the future,
where you land on a collection
like this, of puzzle games.
And you can see that there
are a number of them there.
And instead of going
to the Play Store, when
we click one of these links,
it will launch directly
into the Instant experience.
So this is "Bubble
Witch 3 Saga" from King.
It loads instantly.
And in about 30
seconds here, I'm
going to be able to
complete this entire map.
I have to save these glorious
owls, which are being shielded
by these powerful bubbles.
And I'm able to get a sense
for what this game is like.
I'm able to compare to games
that I've played before.
And if I can aim properly,
I will finish this map.
Think about that-- right into
the game play experience.
And what's particularly
powerful about this
is that I can do this again.
So I'm loading up another game.
This is "Panda
Pop" from Jam City.
It's built with Unity.
And again, jump right into
the gameplay experience.
And now I have a
good reference point.
So I'm looking for an
awesome puzzle game.
I kind of know that I want
to play something like this,
but this is definitely a
really great way for me
to understand what I
like about the game,
understand whether or not it's
worth ultimately installing it.
And it takes about another
30 seconds to finish this.
So for the purposes
of brevity, I
won't go all the way through it.
But the point is is that
if I had 10 minutes,
I could have played
10 games or more.
And because it's instant,
because it's using Google Play
Instant technology, I don't
have to then go back and remove
10 games after the fact.
It's a great way to explore.
And if we can do this,
if we can do that,
and we can enable that
kind of experience,
we'll have fundamentally changed
how people discover games.
You're playing the game rather
than just reading about it.
Let's go back to the slides.
And we've been working with
an amazing set of partners
in the lead up to today.
These partners and their games
cover the complete spectrum.
So we know that whether
you're a giant publisher
or an indie studio; whether
your games are huge,
hundreds of megabytes, or
small; Google Play instant
will work for you.
And when you build
an instant app,
it will be accessible
from almost anywhere.
And now I'm going to talk to
you about the discovery services
that Play and
Google can provide.
You can look at them
as a bundle of services
that are unlocked by
building an instant app.
So there's Try
Now on the store--
it's very popular-- which Jon
walked you through earlier.
And Jon already showed
you what a big brand
like Supercell with "Clash
Royale" can accomplish.
And based on
Supercell's experience,
they're excited about making
their games accessible
and introducing them
to a wider audience
through Google Play Instant.
So we know the impact is there
for the biggest publishers.
For less established
brands, the impact
can be even more profound.
"Mighty Battles"
from Hothead Games
has seen a 2x uplift on
click-throughs on their store
listing, attracting a whole
set of new users to their game.
So just to carry
Jon's analogy forward,
imagine if this half of the
audience was installing.
And before, this
half of the audience,
the ones with
commitment problems,
were doing nothing, abandoning.
In the world of "Mighty
Battles" with Try
Now, this half of the
room, still installing.
So that's good.
This half of the room,
everybody is clicking Try Now.
Everybody is clicking Try Now.
That is transformative to them.
And our preliminary data
shows that the inside app
drove a 19% uplift in user
acquisitions for them.
It exceeded their expectations.
And here is what their director
of marketing, Oliver Birch,
said.
So Hothead Games is
excited about the results
and are looking
to expand instant
to the rest of their
portfolio of games.
In fact, they've
already started working
on their next instant
app for "Hero Hunters."
And to be clear,
everything I just said
is about the Try
Now button alone.
But there's more.
Soon, coming to the store will
be instant-enable banners.
So when users click
the banner, they
will be directly launched
into the instant experience.
Picture something like this
being the first experience
a user has with your game--
being able to become
instantly immersed
in the heart of battle.
We'll also have an
evergreen-curated collection
of the best instant experiences,
providing another way
to get your games discovered.
Our partners also see ads
as a great application
of the instant format.
In fact, most of
our largest partners
are particularly
excited about this one.
And that's why I'm happy to say
that we're already exploring
ways to bring instant apps
to AdWords and Universal App
Campaigns, or UAC for short.
And in the coming
months, once you've
created an instant
experience for your game,
UAC can start
automatically driving users
to it from its ads.
Belinda from our ad team will
actually be up here a little
bit later to talk to you more
about innovations in the ads
team.
And then there is Google Search.
You might have heard of it.
And in the near
future, you'll be
able to search for a game
like "Words With Friends 2"
and launch the instant
experience directly
from the search results.
And as you've already
seen, the Play Games app
provides a sneak
peek at the future
where playing becomes the
way users discover, evaluate,
and compare games.
So that covers all the
Play and Google discovery
services you unlock just
by building an instant app.
But the store and Google
properties are just the start.
I think Bernard Kim, Zynga's
president of studios,
captures this perfectly
here with this quote.
The opportunity goes
well beyond the store
to the multitude
of new entry points
Google Play Instant
makes possible.
And when you put cool technology
in the hands of a partner
like Zynga's, great
things happen.
New, exciting ideas are formed.
Ideas like social invites,
sharing, and cross-promotion
are huge opportunities
that Zynga identified.
So what I'm about to show
you are Zynga's explorations
of what's possible with
Google Play Instant.
So can we roll the video?
So ideas like social invites.
So a friend sends you an invite
in "Words With Friends 2."
You click the invite.
And you're taken
right into the game,
where you can complete
a turn before you're
prompted to install.
Here's a great example of
social sharing from "Farmville."
So imagine one of your friends
shares their farm with you.
They're proud of it.
They've been working
on it for a while.
And when you accept the
invitation over chat,
you jump directly
into the game and can
start engaging with your
friend's farm right away.
Not the Play Store listing.
Not a web page.
You jump right into
the experience.
And cross-promotion is
another great use for instant.
So imagine you just completed
a battle in "Dawn of Titans"
and you clicked through
the cross-promotion link
to "CSR 2."
And we're instantly transported
into a race like this.
It's visceral.
You get to experience the game.
And you don't have
to wait, because it's
instant, of course.
And that's the promise
of instant apps.
So let me stop
there for a second.
That was a lot to absorb.
So to recap, we just covered,
one, Play services including
Try Now, banners, collections,
and the Play Games app; two,
beyond Play, we talked
about the power of ads
in Google Search; and three, we
covered new game entry points
like social invites,
sharing, and cross-promotion,
each benefiting from
Google Play Instant.
Now if I've done
my job right, you
should all be excited about
the opportunity of Google Play
Instant.
So the logical next
question is, so how
do I build an instant app?
I'm glad you asked.
[LAUGHTER]
The short answer is you'll be
able to build your instant app
the same way you build games
today and with the same tools.
And there are three
things that we've changed.
So first, we raised the size
limit to 10 megabytes just
for games.
We've enabled the
progressive download
of executable code and assets
with a split install API.
And very importantly,
we've added full support
for native code and are
integrating with game engines.
And there are two key reasons
why we made these changes.
First, games are just bigger.
On average, games are over
twice the size of apps.
And we've increased the
size limit to 10 megabytes
because the
expectations of players
are different for
apps and games.
And progressive download
gets users into games faster
because you don't have to
download the whole thing
at once anymore.
And second, most games today are
either built with a game engine
like Unity or Cocos
or native code.
So what we've done is
enable game developers
to use the tools they're
already comfortable with
to build instant apps.
And this is vitally important,
as this quote from Playtika
illustrates above,
because it means
that you can use the same
codebase as your full game
to build your instant app.
You can build from
your same codebase.
That's incredibly powerful.
And to make that possible
for Unity developers,
to be honest, probably most
of you in the audience,
we have to work closely with the
world's most widely used game
engine, Unity.
More than 60% of mobile games
on Play are made with Unity,
and we're excited to
announce that we're
partnering with Unity to
support Google Play Instant.
And through this
close collaboration,
millions of Unity
developers will
be able to optimize their
current and future games
for Google Play Instant.
We're also excited to
announce that Cocos
is adding instant support
to their IDE Cocos creator.
But they're going beyond just
adding support in the IDE.
They're getting
tools to simplify
the process of trimming down
the game into instant form.
And we have a treat
for you today.
Cocos has provided a sneak
preview of their integration
with instant apps,
and it's awesome.
Can we roll this video?
All right.
So imagine you built a
game in Cocos Creator,
and you're ready to build
your instant experience.
You click Android
Instant as the platform,
and you enter in
a recording mode.
And what's happening
here is that, as you're
playing the game,
all the assets that
are being used in this
portion of the game
are tagged and time-stamped, the
portions of code that are used.
And once this recording
experience is over
and you finish killing
all these zombies,
you then can go into
the refactor stage.
And the refactor stage will look
a little bit familiar to you
probably if you're familiar
with nonlinear editing suites.
So what's happened is there's
been a screen capture created
while you've been recording
what assets are used.
So you can understand
exactly where
you are when you're
trying to understand
where this asset was used.
And all of the assets
are clustered together.
You can drill down
into each one of them,
and you can swap out
assets and hide them.
And that red bar
there determines
where the APK cutoff will be.
So you move it to the left, all
the numbers of files go down
as well as the megabytes.
And conversely, as you
move it to the right,
you're getting a bigger game.
But this allows you
with pinpoint accuracy
to figure out what
portions of your game
make a great fit for
instant and greatly reduces
the skill involved that would
otherwise require refactoring.
And so now you're just going
back into the regular flow--
build, compile, play-- which
we'll wrap up here in a second.
Yes.
And fast-forward here, and
you can see the output.
So this is just an early preview
of what they are building.
And there are lots of
details still to work out.
But we think this represents
a great path to easy, painless
instant app development.
So to recap, I want
you to walk away
keeping these three
things in mind.
One, Google Play Instant will
transform game discovery.
Two, top developers are on
board and already succeeding.
And three, game devs large and
small can build instant apps
And this is just the
beginning of our journey.
We're going to
continue to invest
in faster startup times,
better tools, and new discovery
services.
But before I go, I wanted to
show you one more awesome demo,
just one last one.
Let's see.
So this demo, in fact--
I wasn't sure at the
beginning of the day
if we were going to
be able to do it.
So I should have an
email with a link to it.
Just give me a sec here.
OK.
OK, we're ready to go.
So what you're about to
see here is a demonstration
of what's possible with
Google Play Instant.
This is a tech demo
that Zynga just
pulled together with "CSR 2."
So let's say that a friend just
got an awesome car like this
Lamborghini and wants to brag
about it, because who wouldn't?
It's a pretty awesome car.
They could send you a link,
just like Jake did to me.
And you'd be able to jump
right into this experience.
And it's already
a stunning model.
You can open up the doors
and interact with it.
But there is more.
This, in fact, has
an AR mode where
I can place this amazing
car right here on the stage.
I can shrink it down here,
spin it around some more,
open up the doors.
I can actually go and take
a seat in my dream car.
Let's see if I can do that.
And I can look at these
most insane details.
I don't know why they're all
there, but it's cool in AR
to be able to do this, right?
So let's take a step back.
That was "CSR 2."
It was a game that in full
form is over a gigabyte.
It's built on Unity.
It's built on ARCore.
So if "CSR 2" can work
for Google Play Instant,
any game can.
So that's the message I want
to leave you all with, unless I
can see the rest of my slides.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE
And-- oh, there we go.
Ask and you will
receive apparently.
All right, so be on the
lookout out for the rest
of these posters around GDC.
And if you have
an Android device,
you can open Google Assistant.
Click the camera.
Hold it up to a QR code to play
the instant version of "Words
With Friends."
So what's next?
Well, if you haven't
already, first
go check out the
Google Play Instant
collection on the Play Store.
And then we're not quite
ready to open up the Games
beta to everyone just yet.
Today, you can go check out the
case studies and documentation
at g.co/instantapps.
Click on the Stories
link for case studies
that explain how our partners
optimize their games for Google
Play Instant.
And last, you can sign up at
g.co/play/instantbeta to get
updates on our progress.
And we'll email you
with the latest news.
And with that, again, one last
time, thank you for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]